Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Гарного вечора п'ятниці, раді бачити
вас з нами.
Норберт Леманн пізніше розповість про спорт.
Президент Німеччини виступив зі зверненням до народу:
«Дивіденди, які ми збирали в епоху миру, вичерпалися,
і для Німеччини починається епоха протистояння
зустрічним вітрам.»
У своєму зверненні до народу
президент готує країну до важких років у найближчому
майбутньому.
До інших тем:
Європа без двигунів внутрішнього згоряння:
в ЄС з 2035 року на законодавчому рівні заборонять
продаж нових авто на бензині і дизелі.
Що Ілон Маск планує робити з Twitter?
Інтернет-мережа тепер належить
найбагатшій людині світу.
«Ми повинні готуватися до обмежень
і непростих часів», - говорить президент
у своїй програмній промові та
апелює до сильного духу німців.
«Президент Росії Путін намагається розділити Європу
і несе цю отруту в німецьке суспільство.
Важливо укріплювати все, що нас об'єднує.»
Інес Трамс далі.
Президент Штайнмаєр розпочав свою промову
зі згадки про ранок 24 лютого,
коли все у світі змінилося.
Жахлива ситуація в Україні
ознаменувала остаточний гіркий провал
багаторічних політичних зусиль,
в тому числі моїх зусиль,
спрямованих на запобігання саме цим
жахливим подіям.
24 лютого стало епохальним переломним моментом.
Штайнмайєр, який нещодавно був з візитом
в Україні,
говорить, що Путін не просто грає проти правил,
він перекинув шахівницю
і перетворив на руїни європейський безпековий порядок.
Якщо ми подивимось на Росію сьогодення,
там не буде місця старим мріям.
Сьогодні наші країни стоять одна проти одної.
Штайнмайєр піддався критиці після початку війни,
тому що свого часу на посаді міністра закордонних справ
він прагнув до тісної співпраці з Росією.
У промові він застерігає тих,
хто наполягає на негайних мирних переговорах:
Будь-хто при здоровому глузді має таке бажання.
Лиш справа у тім,
що перед обличчям зла доброї волі недостатньо.
Він чітко пояснює громадянам,
що їх чекають важкі, бурхливі роки -
епоха зустрічного вітру.
У найглибшій кризі з часів возз'єднання Німеччини
важливо мати чітку позицію і бути невибагливими
до ситуації.
Тягар кризи потрібно розділити справедливо між усіма,
але кожна людина мусить долучитися до цього процесу.
Німеччина, наша країна, потребує вашої волі до змін,
потребує вашої відданості нашому суспільству,
аби ми могли потрапити туди,
куди хочемо потрапити!
Він закликає до рішучості у боротьбі зі зміною клімату
та демократичні цінності.
Багаті і бідні, молоді і старі, Схід і Захід
повинні стати разом.
Зміцнювати все, що нас єднає!
Це наше завдання. Давайте виконаємо його!
Заклик президента Німеччини перед викликами часу.
Багато хто хотів би, щоб Штайнмайєр виступив
з цією промовою раніше.
На зв'язку Шакунтала Бенерджі з Берліну.
Як народ оцінює сьогоднішній виступ?
Після тривалої тиші на великій сцені
Штайнмаєр вирішив використати цей виступ,
щоб розповісти країні, що на неї чекає.
З одного боку,
вона стоїть перед епохальним викликом в умовах війни
та численних криз.
З іншого боку, країна зараз в такій точці часу,
де є передумови для того,
щоб легко впоратися з цим викликом.
Це була промова, яка апелювала не до серця, а до розуму.
І до громадянської відповідальності.
Що наразі, безумовно, нелегко сприймається усіма.
Для тих, у кого в умовах кризи справи йдуть погано,
кому доводиться рахувати кожну копійку,
такий заклик взяти себе в руки й вистояти
- це не те, на що вони сподівалися.
Наскільки самокритичним був президент?
Адже він був співвідповідальним за політику ФРН
щодо Росії
під час перебування на посаді
міністра закордонних справ.
Всі, хто очікував великої промови з вибаченнями,
були розчаровані.
Самокритика президента Штайнмаєра,
за винятком однієї репліки, була між рядків.
Він говорив про провал спільних зусиль,
його особистих зусиль,
але в цілому тон промови свідчив про те,
що він змінює свою попередню позицію.
Президент рішуче засудив Росію,
знайшов різкі слова на адресу агресивної війни
та поведінки Путіна.
Він чітко дав зрозуміти, яка його позиція зараз.
Хоча цього було недостатньо,
критики, які припускали,
що він плекає прокремлівські симпатії,
притихли.
Дякую. З Берліну - Шакунтала Бенерджі.
Штайнмаєр також закликав не нехтувати боротьбою
зі зміною клімату.
Тим часом ЄС доречно прийняв рішення про
поступову відмову
від автомобілів на дизелі та бензині.
З 2035 року реєструватимуться лише кліматично
нейтральні автомобілі.
Рішення буде переглянуто у 2026 році.
Так само, як і допустимість використання
синтетичного,
так званого електропалива.
Ульф Реллер розповість детальніше.
Пізно ввечері ЄС прийняв історичне рішення:
епоха класичного двигуна внутрішнього згоряння
закінчується.
Поки що не зрозуміло, що
це означатиме для автопромисловості.
Європейська комісія представить
звіт, в якому проаналізує,
як відмова від двигуна внутрішнього згоряння
змінить автомобільну промисловість,
скільки робочих місць ми отримаємо чи втратимо.
Електротранспорт стане викликом
для німецького автопрому,
оскільки Китай просувається на
світовий ринок з власною продукцією.
Тому німецький автопром очікує, що політики
інвестуватимуть мільярди в інфраструктуру,
таку як, наприклад,
розгалужена система зарядних станцій.
Ми хочемо кліматичної нейтральності.
Хочемо зробити електротранспорт успішним.
Нам це вдасться лише за умови,
якщо політики зараз створять
правильні умови.
ЄС підтримує електротранспорт,
за одним винятком.
Для міністра транспорту Віссінга, FDP,
двері залишаються відкритими.
Для двигунів «електропалива»
ці синтетичні палива є незамінними.
Тому потрібно використовувати всі технології,
які забезпечують кліматично
нейтральну мобільність.
Це електротранспорт, це воднева тяга,
але, звичайно, також і електропаливо.
Відмова від двигуна внутрішнього
згоряння у 2035 році
змушує автовиробників ще більше
інвестувати в електротранспорт.
Саме тому екологи схвалюють це рішення.
Але маємо бути чесними,
це відбувається занадто пізно.
Для того, щоб гарантовано досягти мети в 1,5°,
виробництво нових дизельних та бензинових
автомобілів повинно бути поступово
припинено в Європі до 2028 року.
Електронна транспортна система —
це технологія майбутнього.
ЄС хоче переконати в цьому споживачів.
Що саме означає відмова від двигуна
внутрішнього згоряння для автомобілістів?
Відповіді на найважливіші питання ви можете
прочитати в нашому застосунку «ZDFheute».
Дві актуальні цифри, які привертають увагу:
інфляція в Німеччині продовжує
зростати — з 10,0 до 10,4%.
Це попередній прогноз на жовтень.
Найвищий за останні 70 років.
Енергія та продукти харчування
продовжують дорожчати і стимулюють ріст цін.
Вчора Європейський центральний банк підвищив
ключові процентні ставки через тривалу інфляцію.
Але є і позитивний сюрприз:
у третьому кварталі німецька економіка дещо зросла -
з 0,1 до 0,3% завдяки збільшенню споживчих витрат.
Економісти радше очікували падіння.
Нарешті:
гай-тек мільярдер Ілон Маск купив Twitter
після місяців перемовин і вагань.
Як відомо, Маск віддає за соцмережу
близько 44 млрд євро!
Чималі гроші для компанії,
яка досі майже не приносила прибутку.
До того ж «лишень» близько 238 мільйонів
людей користуються Twitter щодня.
Для порівняння:
Facebook має 1,98 млрд користувачів щодня!
Проте Twitter вважається особливо важливим
каналом поширення думок та новин.
Свен Рікен про це більше.
Людина, раковина.
Ілон Маск пояснює символізм самостійно.
Він хоче почистити Twitter,
змити деякі речі в каналізацію -
ось що означає це відео.
Частина менеджменту відчула
це в перший же день купівлі
і була звільнена з компанії.
Сам Маск пише в Twitter,
чому він вважає мережу вартою покупки.
«Я купив Twitter, тому що важливо, щоб ми (...)
могли обговорювати широкий спектр поглядів,
не вдаючись до насильства.»
Twitter-спільнота святкує покупку, але лише частково.
Деякі користувачі просто пішли.
Коли один з найбагатших людей світу викуповує
найактуальніший майданчик для
публічного дискурсу в багатьох державах
і в односторонньому порядку
змінює правила на свою користь,
це завжди повинно змусити нас замислитися.
Бан Трампа в Twitter може бути знятий,
фільтри, які видаляють кримінальні
заяви в деяких країнах,
можуть стати слабшими або зникнути.
Таким чином, Twitter може стати
ще більшим політичним інструментом.
Той, хто походить зі світу, де свобода
слова цінується понад усе,
порівняно швидко опиниться в біді.
Ілону Маску слід шанувати європейські закони.
Вже обговорюються нові бізнес-моделі:
платні твіти, які будуть виділятися.
Більше трафіку, більше заробітку взагалі,
також отримання плати з користувачів,
а не тільки з рекламодавців -
це можуть бути моделі підписки на певні сервіси,
або ж це може бути комісія з продажу контенту.
У купівлі Twitter є побічний ефект:
альтернативи мережі набирають популярності.
Наприклад, Mastodon, заснований у Німеччині,
неприбутковий і децентралізований.
«Твіти» називаються тут «Tröt» (від нім. «трубити»).
Символьне зображення – слон.
Проєкт поки що не вагомий,
але і Twitter довгий час не був таким.
За рік до виборів у Баварії CSU набирає обертів.
Очевидно, що лідер партії Зедер
хоче забезпечити своє переобрання
на посаду прем'єр-міністра
за допомогою подвійної стратегії.
По-перше, різкі атаки на
«світлофорну» коаліцію в Берліні.
За словами Зедера, це, мабуть,
один з найгірших урядів за всю історію.
По-друге, підкреслити власні сильні сторони.
Штефан Ляйферт повідомляє
з партійної конференції в Аугсбурзі.
У виставковому залі Аугсбурга шумно і гамірно.
За рік до земельних виборів CSU тестує звучання,
імідж та кандидата на передвиборчу кампанію.
Значну частину свого виступу Маркус Зедер
присвятив жорсткій критиці
берлінської «світлофорної» коаліції.
У німців складається враження,
що цей уряд в Берліні
здається перевантаженим,
що цей уряд не справляється
з проблемами, і я думаю,
що «світлофорна» коаліція, напевно,
один з найслабших урядів,
які ми коли-небудь мали
у Федеративній Республіці Німеччина.
Перш за все, Зедер працює проти Зелених -
його головного суперника в Баварії.
У дебатах щодо продовження
використання ядерної енергетики
Зелені, нібито, показали своє справжнє обличчя.
Ви не прокліматична партія,
ви все та ж стара ліва партія, що виступає проти АЕС,
і у вас виступають все ті ж люди:
Клаудія Рот плаче, а Тріттін кричить.
Німеччині це не потрібно.
Зедер оголошує зустрічний проєкт: більше новітніх
технологій та кліматично спрямованої політики.
Настрої на з'їзді стримано-оптимістичні.
Зрозуміло, що всі голоси не збереш і всіх не переконаєш,
це нормально, незалежно від партії.
Сила CSUв тому, що ми говоримо з людьми.
Важливо, що ми виносимо на земельні вибори
свої власні теми і виступаємо за розвиток Баварії.
За рік до виборів CSU об'єднує свої ряди за спиною
Маркуса Зедера.
За рік до виборів нервозність в CSU висока.
Всім зрозуміло, що лише критики на адресу
«світлофорної» коаліції буде недостатньо.
Багатьом не вистачає великого
політичного плану для Баварії.
Зедеру доведеться створити такий план наново,
оскільки через рік від цього залежатиме
його політичне майбутнє.
Кривава війна Путіна для багатьох означає виїзд з країни.
З кінця лютого до Німеччини приїхало
понад мільйон осіб з України.
Але деякі з них вже повертаються на батьківщину.
На війну.
Наш репортер Дара Гасанзаде зустрівся з родиною,
яка зараз починає все спочатку в Одесі.
Сім'я з Миколаєва, але там зараз йдуть запеклі бої.
Повернення до Миколаєва.
Юрій не з'являвся у батьківському домі з березня.
Місто щодня обстрілюють.
Вони дізналися від друзів, що в їхній будинок
також влучили снаряди.
Спочатку вони хочуть на власні очі побачити,
що залишилося від їхнього дому.
Лише одне вікно вціліло.
У Миколаєві немає ні світла, ні води, ні газу.
Як би вони не хотіли, але ремонтувати
будинок батьків Юрія
наразі немає сенсу.
Я бачив фотографії.
Але коли ти бачиш це на власні очі,
то це зовсім інше.
Я знав, що буде важко, але не очікував, що настільки.
Я не побажав би цього нікому в світі.
Зараз вони почуваються в безпеці в Одесі,
саме тут родина хоче побудувати свій новий дім.
Юрій з матір'ю вже пів року перебували у Німеччині
у якості біженців.
За їх словами, їх прийняли найкращі у світі люди,
це було схоже на казку.
Але таку, в якій сім'я жила роздільно.
Без вітчима Костянтина.
Ми були налякані, нічого не знали.
Куди нам йти, як нам поводитись.
Залишатися в Німеччині
чи повертатися в Україну.
Було важко.
Але потім ми вирішили їхати додому.
І це приємне відчуття.
Авіаудари по Одесі тривають,
фронт під Миколаєвом на відстані 200 км.
Але сім'я возз'єдналася.
Після війни вони знову хочуть подорожувати. Разом.
Погляньмо на США.
Під час проникнення до будинку Ненсі Пелосі
було скоєно напад на чоловіка
лідерки фракції демократів.
Він отримав поранення, а нападника було заарештовано.
Мотив досі залишається невідомим.
Можливо, напад був спрямований
на спікерку Палати представників.
На момент нападу її не було вдома.
Електроенергія з вугілля - це фактично
застаріла модель у Німеччині.
З моменту прийняття рішення понад два роки тому,
низка вугільних електростанцій
вже була виведена з енергосистеми.
Але зараз, коли газ треба економити,
вони знову необхідні.
Тому близько десяти вугільних електростанцій
по всій Німеччині
будуть тимчасово під'єднані до енергосистеми.
Одна з них -
електростанція на кам'яному вугіллі Бексбах
у федеральній землі Саар.
Сюзанна Фрайтаг далі.
До цього часу електростанція Бексбах у Саарі
була частиною аварійного резерву.
Відсьогодні вона готова до безперервної роботи,
хоча через високу температуру повітря
ще не вмикалася.
Одна з двох вугільних електростанцій,
які знову вироблятимуть електроенергію.
На повну потужність вони споживатимуть
6000 тонн вугілля на добу.
Запланований поетапний вихід
відкладений через кризу.
У нас дійсно немає іншого вибору.
Ми платимо ціну за затягнутий енергетичний перехід.
Ось чому вони мають повернутися в мережу.
І це дуже проблематично.
Вугілля завозиться тоннами спеціальними потягами,
які насправді вже виведені з експлуатації.
Вони були переобладнані.
25 поїздів на тиждень привозять вугілля
до Саару з Південної Африки, США, Колумбії.
Непросте завдання.
Зараз логісти пристосувалися до того,
що їм більше не потрібно возити вугілля
для електростанцій,
тому що вони не виробляють електроенергію.
І тому потрібен був певний час,
поки ми за допомогою наших постачальників послуг
створили необхідні потужності -
а мова йде про машиністів, поїзди та вагони -
поки ми їх не зібрали разом.
Працівники електростанції підвищують кваліфікацію,
щоб заново освоїти стару техніку.
Старі підприємства планують повернути в експлуатацію.
Звичайно, не вистачає кадрів,
і їх треба перенавчати вже зараз.
Енергія з вугілля дійсно має відійти в минуле.
Однак найближчим часом вона видається незамінною.
Померла велика людина
в історії американського рок-н-ролу.
Джеррі Лі Льюїс, йому було 87 років.
Льюїс справив фурор на сцені
своєю швидкою та потужноюгрою на фортепіано.
У 50-х  Льюїс випустив свій
найбільший хіт «Great Balls of Fire».
*«Great Balls of Fire» Джеррі Лі Льюїса*
Відверті тексти пісень та дикі виступи
створили йому імідж поганого хлопця,
але водночас і одного з останніх
олдскульних рок-н-рольщиків.
А тепер до чудової футбольної гри на дві дії, Норберте.
Матч «Кельн» - «Словацко»,
перший матч Ліги конференцій,
завершився вчора через сім хвилин після
початку в густому чеському тумані.
Сьогодні опівдні гра поновилася.
Наприкінці другого тайму «Кельн» виграв з рахунком 1:0.
В Чехії нема ніякого стимулу.
Гра продовжується з 8-ї хвилини,
на якій закінчили вчора.
Попри хорошу видимість, голів спочатку не було,
на перерву пішли з рахунком 0:0.
«Кельн» заробив право на пенальті.
На 51-й хвилині Флоріан Кайнц не влучає
повз воротаря Філіпа Нгуєна.
На пів години пізніше Ондрей Дуда пробив влучно.
Рахунок 1:0 протримається до кінця
сьогоднішніх 82-х хвилин гри.
Для команди тренера Штеффена Баумгарта,
це означає, що у разі перемоги в
останній груповій грі проти «Ніцци»
«Кельн» може вийти до раунду плей-офф Ліги Європи.
До Ліги Європи.
Вчора ввечері німці двічі перемогли.
Почнемо з «Фрайбурга».
«Фрайбург» поступалися до 90-ї хвилини після того,
як Ель-Арабі відкрив рахунок на користь «Пірея» - 0:1.
А потім Лукас Кюблер заслужено зрівняв рахунок - 1:1.
ФК очолив групу і впевнено вийшов до раунду плей-офф.
І «Уніон» також має хороші шанси на успіх.
Гол вечора у виконанні берлінця Робіна Кнохе
на 68-й хвилині
за домашню перемогу над «Брагою» з рахунком 1:0.
До жіночої Ліги чемпіонів,
мюнхенки обіграли «Бенфіку»
з рахунком 3:2 у Лісабоні вчора ввечері.
Видовищна гра зі щасливим фіналом для «Баварії»
завдяки голу на останній хвилині.
Цією перемогою мюнхенки завдячують
своєму менталітету.
Після перерви «Бенфіка» збільшує свою перевагу 1:0,
тому, що воротарка «Баварії»
Марія Грос допустила помилку.
Але «Баварія» не здається.
На 67-й хвилині Максиміліан Ралль забила
вирішальний м'яч - рахунок 1:2.
Натхненна цим,
чемпіонка Європи з Англії Джорджія Стенвей
зрівняла рахунок незадовго до завершення матчу.
Стенвей стала переможницею матчу,
у компенсований час вона забила вирішальний гол - 3:2.
І це все, що стосується спорту.
Дякую, Норберте.
Нас чекають дуже м'які вихідні.
Докладніше за мить від Крісти Орбен.
У «heute journal» о 22:00
Анна Ґеллінек розмовляє з міністром транспорту
про відмову від двигуна внутрішнього згоряння.
Вся команда «heute» бажає вам гарних вихідних.
До завтра, бувайте.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогоднішній день розпочався помірно,
а потім дуже потепліло,
до 28,7°C.
У Мюльгаймі в Баден-Вюртемберзі
зафіксували найвище значення
за останні десять днів жовтня,
що є рекордом за десятиліття.
П'ятірка лідерів: Фрайбург, Еммендінген, Бухенбах,
всі - у Баден-Вюртемберзі.
Але так повсюдно в Німеччині сьогодні,
як показує Гарсебах в Саксонії з 26,4°C,
булозареєстровано значно більше 25 градусів.
Найближча ніч не буде такою м'якою, як минула, але
здебільшого температура повітря
залишається двозначною.
Лише на південному сході температура падає до 7°C.
Тут також переважно ясно, проте
утворюється найгустіший туман.
В інший час - від мінливої до дуже хмарної погоди.
Завтра на півночі і в центрі
утримається сильна хмарність,
можливий невеликий дощ.
Найбільше сонця буде на півдні і на
північному краю Середньогір'я.
І ось цей фен, який об'єднався
зі слабким південним вітром,
що допомагає денними максимумами,
які завтра досягнуть 26°C з підвітряного боку гір
та на південному заході.
Неділя також буде дуже м'якою.
Лише з нового тижня температура повільно піде на спад.
Бувайте.